in person
this year I was able to travel to some
of your countries
and I've had the opportunity to witness
firsthand the excellent work you are
doing on the ground
you're the ones who are bridging
bringing Europe to the world and I
really really want to thank you for that
work because it is so necessary and you
are doing such an excellent work in this
very difficult times
thank you
so some of the visits we've witnessed
together will be etched in my memory
forever
one of them was my very first trip to
Ukraine in April and I'm sure that mati
if he's here with us
you will very much remember that
when we arrived in butcher
Russian soldiers had just left
we saw body bags lined up
we saw Mass graves right next to a
church
it's a horror and these are pictures
I'll never ever forget in my life
but when I went back to kief
this year I think it was in June and it
was in September
I saw a country that is eager to take
back
it's life and its normal routine
so roads and bridges have been repaired
shops were open again we saw people in
the streets
and this tells me one thing
even if Russian missiles are now Falling
Again on Ukrainian cities they won't
break the Ukrainian spirit this is for
sure
and look at what had happened on Monday
morning in the Metro stations in Kief
you might have read it
thousands of people took shelter
Underground
and they started to sing
songs of Hope
songs of pride
songs that tell the Russians we are not
afraid
and us the European Union we must keep
supporting Ukraine through thick and
thin as long as it takes
just like we've done since February
our response to the invasion has
surprised
not only Putin but I think the whole
world
we put together the first sanctions in a
matter of days
and then it was followed the first
package of sanctions by eight
consecutive sanctions packages to leave
no stone unturned
the latest package in response to the
Sham referenda in the occupying the
Ukrainian territories
we've supported Ukraine with funds
summing up to 19 billion euros since the
beginning of the war
and there's not included what the
European peace facility is giving to the
equipment with military capabilities and
weapons
we have given full support and immediate
temporary protection to the Ukrainian
refugees that were coming to the
European Union I think it were over 8.1
million refugees that came to the
European Union around about 5 million
have gone back to Ukraine that's a good
sign too but it is amazing to see how
fast we were in welcoming them people
opened their hearts and their homes and
we gave them immediately the temporary
protection
which was access to the labor market
access to schools access to health care
for example
we have enabled the solidarity Lanes
so that Ukrainian farmers can keep
feeding the world
sixty percent sixty percent of Ukrainian
grain is leaving the country via our
European solidarity Lanes
we are restoring schools and co-leading
of the Reconstruction effort
and we have granted enthusiastically
candidate status to Ukraine and I think
we all can take pride in this work
foreign
it shows basically how much we can
achieve with unity
and with determination
and we must stay the course
especially now
as the war enters in a new phase
the illegal annexation of four Ukrainian
regions by Russia
brings the challenge against the
International System to a completely new
level
Putin has taken
Sovereign Ukrainian land
with an unprovoked act of aggression
he has forced people to vote at gunpoint
and he has even threatened to use
nuclear weapons if ukrainians reclaim
the land that belongs to them
this is worrying not only for Russia's
Neighbors
this is an attack against the entire U.N
Charter
Putin has even asked in his speech on
annexation and I quote who did ever
agree on a rules-based global order
end of quote well the Russians did
certainly
they did did it when they signed the U.N
Charter
just like all other nations of the world
and when they negotiated the Helsinki
Final Act
the rules-based global order belongs to
the world
it is the best antidote against
Perpetual instability in all continents
and all nations in the world see this
interestingly
even some of Russia's closest allies
are questioning Putin's war of choice
and refusing to recognize the Shem
referendum
the Samarkand Summit where China and
India have clearly voiced concerns about
the war was a fiasco for Russia
but there is no room for complacency
about this
Russia's failure alone
once saved the rules-based global order
because the kremlin's revisionism is not
the only nor the most serious threat to
the rules-based order
the so-called No Limit partnership
declared by Vladimir Putin and Xi
Jinping
is also a clear challenge
to the post-war order built on the core
values of the UN Charter
and of course
we are observing carefully
the aftermath of the 20th Congress of
the Chinese Communist Party
to see any changes to China's
International posture
independent of this
we need to counter This Global challenge
we must rebuild trust in our Global
goals
and our Global rules and the universal
values at their heart
and we all know that this is not an easy
task
I was at the United Nations last month
and I have listened to the concerns of
countries from all over the world
just like you do it every single day in
your work
many countries feel that the global
economy
and the International System do not work
for them
some have even fallen for Russia's
propaganda
Russians propaganda that is trying to
deflect blame for the causes of the
energy and food crisis
and therefore all of us in this room
must speak up
and stand up for the truth
and I know that you are doing this
tirelessly every single day
I know this is tough I know this is hard
work I know that sometimes you are
exhausted and we think like but I've
said that over and over again but I just
want to thank you for that because this
is the essence of your work and this is
the essence of the trust that is built
abroad into the European Union
I believe
Europe must always speak up for the
values we believe in
and support everyone who is fighting for
these values
for instance
the brave Iranian women who demand
freedom and equality
a young woman was killed by the
so-called morality police
thousands of peaceful protesters are
being beaten and detained men and women
lawyers and journalists activists and
ordinary citizens
this is a cry for equality it's a cry
for women's rights and our message must
be Crystal Clear we must call for the
violence to stop women must have a
chance to choose and we must hold
accountable those who are responsible
for the repression of women so I believe
now is the time to sanction these people
who are responsible the shocking
violence inflicted on the Iranian people
cannot stay answered and we have to work
on sanctions together
but there's more
in these times of transformation
and these times of turmoil
Euros Europe must even engage more on
the global stage
we must consolidate our capacity to
protect our values we must reach out to
all countries
from like-minded democracies
to others who may share some of our
interests on specific issues
so today I would like to draw some
lessons
on how we can engage with different
partners
first of all
with like-minded democracies
second with future members of our Union
third with our wider neighborhood and
finally with countries all across the
world as a means to promote our
interests and to advance our values on
global stage
so let me begin with the like-minded
partners
never before never before
have I experienced such an intense
cooperation with the White House as I
did this year
it is a cooperation we have built since
the start of President Biden's mandate
when we managed to find a solution to
long-standing issues you know them all
such as the steel tariffs the air was
Boeing dispute and securing data flow
and our cooperation got even stronger in
the run-up to Russia's invasion
I was in Washington in November as
tension started to rise at our eastern
border you recall Belarus
now we saw the growing threat
and we confirmed our support to
Ukraine's Independence and territorial
integrity
so we prepared these sanctions very
early this year already with the White
House
and when Ukraine invaded was invaded by
Russia we were ready to act
we coordinated our sanctions round after
round
we stepped up our energy coordination
and energy supplies on both sides it
helped enormously that I had the
agreement with President Biden on the
LNG and they really stepped up in
delivering LNG towards the European
Union
and this made it possible for us
to diversify away from Russian fossil
fuels
and now
the transatlantic bond is stronger than
ever
at a crucial time for Europe
this is not only about our friends in
the United States
but about all our like-minded partners
this core of like-minded democracies
share our values
and our outlook on the world
they are our most natural partners
on all the most pressing issues of our
times
and let me mention three of these issues
first on energy
as you all witness Russia keeps using
its fossil fuels as a weapon against us
and like-minded partners like the United
States and for example Norway have
massively stepped up and helped us Break
Free
from our very dangerous dependency
let me give you two figures
at the beginning of the war if you look
at pipeline gas the imported pipeline
gas
41 was imported from Russia
now we're down to 7.5 in only eight
months
this is a huge move it's an enormous
decrease necessary decrease we would
have never ever been able to do that if
it wouldn't have been for our close
friends and partners like for example
Norway and like the United States with
LNG coming in
so now we have to work even more closely
with exactly those partners
to calm down the price of gas Imports
because we all see
that because of the Russian Behavior
cutting gas supplies to the European
Union overall energy scarce in the world
the market is really tight tired so the
prices are skyrocketing
and therefore we have started talks with
Norway
we want to find deals that can be
beneficial for both sides
our partners have an interest to secure
long-term contracts of course with us
the largest market on Earth
and at the same time to invest in
Renewables the Norwegians say
if we lower prices
less revenues will go to the wealth fund
which is for the Next Generation so you
take something away from the Next
Generation
let's look together into the topic of
Renewables and we of course have an
interest to curb the crazy Peaks and
energy prices while also transforming
towards Renewables so there is a lot of
common ground
second example
the International Investment
the United States and other partners
share of value-based approach to
infrastructure investment
and we have the same goals
for instance to speed up the transition
to clean energy or to strengthen
Healthcare in developing countries
so why don't we team up with them on
join projects and complementary
Investments
and this is exactly what we are planning
together with the United States
President Biden and I are convening a
leader Summit really to push forward a
value-based investment agenda for the
world
I'll come back to that later that's
global gateway
but I just want to mention the third
example
that shows how important these moves are
with our best friends that is raw
materials
take lithium or take rare earth metals
they are vital for green and digital
transition no wind turbine no solar
panel without
these raw materials
the demand for them will exponentially
increase that's for sure that is good
news first of all
because it shows that the green
transition is progressing that's good
the not so good news is
one country
dominates the whole Global Market
and that's China
so in addition
these resources should always be
extracted in a responsible way that
should be our goal both for the
environment and for local communities
so part of the solution is to step up
our cooperation with like-minded
Partners like Canada like Chile or like
Australia because together we can both
secure the resources we need
and promote a value-based approach to
the extraction of raw materials
we must mobilize our Collective power
to shape Global goods and the World of
Tomorrow
my second point
is about future members of our Union
it's now a year ago that I visited the
Western Balkans
I was so obvious
that our opponents look at the Western
Balkans as a geopolitical chessboard
their goal is
to drive a wedge between the Western
Balkans and the rest of Europe
and yet the overwhelming majority and
that's heartwarming the overwhelming
majorities of citizens in the western
Balkans aspire to be part of the
European Union
and that is why we must strengthen the
credibility of our accession process
this year the opening of accession
process of the accession process and the
negotiations with Albania and North
Macedonia was a true Milestone finally
it was tough to get there to say the
least
but we are there now that's important we
must make sure that every positive step
that is done in a country that the
country takes brings it really closer to
the European Union and in parallel we
must push the integration of our
economies even further
one year ago I worked on an EU funded
Bridge connecting Croatia with Bosnia
and Herzegovina
I saw Railway projects I saw schools I
saw hospitals and kindergartens that
were financed all across the region by
the European Union
so this kind of Engagement is even more
relevant today as the Fallout of Putin's
energy war is also hitting the region
two weeks ago I was in Sofia for the
inauguration of a new gas interconnector
with grease
it will serve not only Bulgaria but also
North Macedonia and Serbia
as the Western Balkans are asking for
support ahead of a difficult winter this
is exactly the way to go
contrast foreign influence in Europe
through more cooperation and a stronger
European perspective
Ukraine and Moldova are now candidates
for joining to joining our Union
and today we have proposed to Grant
candidate status to Bosnian Herzegovina
in the college decision
we have recognized Georgia's European
perspective too
so Wind of Change is once again blowing
through Europe and we have to capture
this momentum we have to push for this
momentum the Western Balkans belong in
our family and we have to make this very
very clear
it is a bit like in the 1970s
when Spain Portugal and Greece choose
democracy
oh when Freedom Fighters tore down the
Berlin Wall I vividly remember that
of course it is up to the candidate
countries to reform the economies and
the institutions and to advance towards
our Union
but it is our responsibility to support
them in every possible way I think that
is Europe's moment and it's up to us to
seize that moment
dears and the ambassadors our neighbors
face the same challenges
as we Face Russian aggression
energy and security
climate change
the threats to our open societies
there's an urgent need to work with all
of them including those who do not seek
to join our Union and this is the third
angle I want to look at on how we can
engage with different partners
this is actually what led to the first
meeting of the European political
community in Prague last week
44 countries have come together with a
common agenda
when it comes to European security
to the green and digital transition
to defending our Democratic way of life
we all share
a common sense of purpose
and I was glad I must say that our
British friends also decided to join
that's good
there's a lot of work to do together
take our trilateral energy for example
that we closed in June
with Egypt and Israel
it has played an important role in our
strategy to get rid of the Russian
fossil fuels
but my visits in Cairo and Jerusalem
were about much more than gas
because our goal remains the transition
away from fossil fuels and the
Mediterranean countries hold an immense
potential for renewable energy
for example we have launched a new
hydrogen partnership
that looks very promising for both
Europe and Egypt
and at the same time we're working in
the same direction with other Northern
African countries too because we know we
need the energy we need renewable energy
we need the hydrogen and those Northern
African countries have in abundance all
the resources that are necessary
so all of a sudden this energy crisis
that we see at the moment being
makes a huge tectonic shift in the
region because we are diversifying away
from Russia and just let me give you one
figure
before the war the European Union
was 75 of the global demand of pipeline
gas 75 so this huge demand is moving
away from Russia
and turning towards the global South
not only looking for fossil fuels right
now as we need them immediately but
mainly looking at a future that is with
renewable energy that's clean and where
they have the other side of the
Mediterranean they have the resources in
abundance
so Europe can promote and the company
their transition
from a fossil fuel economy for all of us
towards a zero Net Zero future
this is Europe's offer to third
countries starting with our with our
neighbors
it is based on our European interests
and on our values and it is designed to
deliver long-lasting benefits to the
countries that choose to do business
with us
of course as I said it is not only about
energy
in Cairo I also announced that we will
invest 3 billion euros to improve Food
Systems in the region
millions of people in the Middle East
and North Africa
are now facing the consequences of
Putin's war on Ukrainian crops
it is to address this crisis that we
created the so-called solidarity lanes
for Ukrainian experts over 10 million
tons of Ukrainian grain oil seeds and
other products have already been
exported via our solidarity Lanes
today over 60 percent of Ukrainian food
experts rely on these Lanes
and 30 percent of Ukraine's grain
exports are going immediately to low and
middle income countries in Africa in the
Middle East and in Asia
so I think it's very important that we
set the record straight
it is Putin who created with his work
the food crisis and it is Europe that is
working to end it and that's the story
that we have to tell all together
the Middle East and North Africa also
face of course a long-term food security
issue
you know that local agriculture needs to
adapt to the changing climate a modern
technology offers a great number of
solutions
so from Precision Irrigation to Vertical
farming to new crops adapted to climate
change but they have to be brought to
the region
so Europe can contribute with both
investment and of course world-class
expertise
that's the reason why we have set aside
7.7 billion euros
only until 2024 so it's a lot of money
for a short time
for the food security topic
countries all across our region have an
urgent need to transform the economies
for the challenges of a new era
and our Union's greatest strengths has
always been its transformative power
our capacity to promote economic and
social progress through cooperation
and it is in this spirit that we must
also step up our engagement in Central
Asia
the region is a gateway between Europe
Russia and China
and it is going through an era of
turbulent transformation
some countries are pushing for reforms
that seemed Unthinkable just a few
months ago
and they deserve all our political and
economic support
so this is the time to enhance our
economic engagement in Central Asia
and provide
alternatives to the region and to be
connected to the global economy
I want Europe to be a partner for change
in Central Asia
because
the global geopolitics are also changing
you know that tectonic plates are
shifting and in times like these we must
be ready to sail uncharted waters
we must engage beyond our immediate
neighborhood and the circle of our
traditional allies
I think only if we do this
can we contribute
into shaping the future
of fast-changing regions and make a
positive difference
in the lives of millions of people
and this leads me to my fourth and final
point on Europe's Global engagement
at the beginning of this year I had the
opportunity to visit Senegal
and meet a group of young entrepreneurs
and they told me about all the obstacles
they face
but it was amazing to see how much
energy how much talent these young
people in Africa and Senegal had and
showed and then I visited a national
project for vaccine Manufacturing
which we are financing through global
gateway investment program
a place where Africa's pharmaceutical
Independence is taking shape with
Europe's support it is mRNA vaccines
being produced in Africa for Africa so
just the step we have to do it has been
one year now since we launched our
global gateway investment program
and since then the demand for strong and
value-based infrastructure investment
program has only grown stronger
first
covet has highlighted the urgency of
investing in resilient Health Systems
but also for example in the digital
infrastructure
second more and more countries are
dealing with the rise in energy and food
prices
and third a belt and Road depth crisis
is now in full swing
tens of countries are massively indebted
with China
eight of these countries from Angola to
Laos
will spend in 2022 more than two percent
of their gross national income to pay
the debt to China
our global gateway investment is about
about giving countries a better choice
to give them an alternative
it's Investments that will be
sustainable
not only for our partners finances
that's important yes but also for the
environment and of course for the local
communities they have to benefit from
that
and I mentioned our investment in
vaccine Manufacturing in Africa that
we're also now extending to Latin
America
there's so much to do for instance we
are financing new energy and transport
corridors in Africa we will invest in
clean power generation in the
electrification of rural areas
in the connection between landlocked
regions and the big cities and the coast
or take the Asian Pacific where the
footprint of Chinese investment is
massive of course
a good a good example is our new just
transition partnership with Vietnam
which aims to accelerate the transition
from cold
into the Renewables that's a huge leap
forward and we're supporting that and
we're supporting the Pacific state of
Kiribati to build a new Harbor that will
bring new opportunities to one of the
islands while respecting The Fragile
environment
so global gateway is the opportunity
to end unhealthy dependencies
and to invest in Partnerships of equals
instead that is our offer to the world
300 billion of possible investment but
we need the good project we need the
mature projects and that's where we need
you
you are the ones who know the regions
you're the ones who know the partners we
need your advice we need your knowledge
and I know that I can rely on that
this is where your role as ambassadors
is so crucial
you are basically our ears on the ground
Europe needs you we need your knowledge
we need your expertise
we need I mean you know it all in the
region your connections to the region
Europe needs you to identify ideas and
projects for global gateway that can
make a real difference
in our partner countries and you are in
the unique position to bring together
Our member states that are part of
global gateway to focus on common
strategies and uncommon priorities we
all know that it is so important to be
present in the regions where you are the
ambassadors that we show this is one
European voice that is speaking to our
partners therefore bringing together all
member states bringing together the
European level I very much rely on you
because you are the ones who can make it
happen
we all know that we must do more
together
more than ever before Our Fate so
Europe's fate depends on our Global
Outreach
the war in Ukraine will be decided first
and foremost by Ukraine's Brave fighters
in Carson
in hakif
and all along the front line we know
that
but it will also be decided by our
Global Response to Russia's aggression
so we need all continents to rise up in
defense for the rules-based order
because the rules-based order belongs to
all nations in the world
the war in Ukraine is not only a
European War
it is a war
for the future of the entire world
so Europe's Horizon can only be the
entire world
and I truly count on you to keep up the
excellent work you're doing and to bring
our voice and our values to all corners
of the world let me wish you a very good
conference many thanks for listening to
me and in this sense Long Live Europe
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]